hello everyone and welcome to game 8
from the Women's World Championship it
is a juvenile versus Leighton Jane and
you know what happened first four games
ended in a drawden in game five eliting
game at defeated Jew engine uh taking
the lead in the match then uh we had the
game six and game seven uh which also
ended in a draw and this is now game
eight which is uh well a very lovely
game but the match is no longer played
in Shanghai we already said that the
first six games will be played in
Shanghai which is juventions home City
and uh late in Jay is from Chongqing so
the the other six games are being played
in Chongqing so if you guys uh are
interested in the city this is uh
Chongqing where uh the the the last six
games of the match will be played unless
we will have tie breaks uh some history
behind it it was uh the area was
conquered in 360 16 BC so over 2 000
years old really and the city was not
open to 49ers uh up until 1891. so like
really for for two Millennia they did
not allow anyone to come in and then in
1997 the government merged Chongqing
with several surrounding districts
making it a very very large municipality
uh if you're wondering uh how how large
it is it's some 29 million people so you
know uh just uh just to have some
background on where the match is being
played so that being said let's check it
out Juan Jun has the white pieces and
she opens with Pont uh sorry with Knight
to F3 she goes for the Arete opening we
have found the D5 we have E3 and pawn to
C5 grabbing the full Center here which
is not uncommon when you play the red
you want to control the central with the
pieces and of course the black will try
to take advantage of this by taking
control of the center with the pawn so
upon the B3 uh Knight to C6 and now
Bishop to B2 we have Pawn to A6 and pawn
to G3 Queen to C7 and there is a game
where that uh reached this exact same
position as often
it was played in 20 2017 in the Isle of
Man tournament where uh Pawn to C4 was
played but here we have Pawn to D4 and
it is now already as of move six that we
have a completely new game which is
absolutely incredible uh for a World
Chess Championship
um Magic game so okay C captures on D4
we have e captures and Bishop to G for
now makes sense you want to develop
inning the knights will Bishop to G2
they are also adding another Defender E6
this is a beautiful setup now for uh for
Lay as she put her pawns on light
squares the bishop is already out of the
cage so you don't have to worry about
that and the dark Square Bishop is free
to roam in between the dark squares that
are that are available to him so castles
uh we have Knight to F6 and now Knight
beat the D2 with Bishop to D6 again both
players just putting pieces on optimal
squares and pawn to C4 uh we have
castles and pawn to A3 now we have Pawn
to A5 stopping B4 and pawn to H3
charging the bishop here so of course
you don't want to give up your Bishop
pair to quickly Bishop H5 and queen to
E2 developing the queen and connecting
Rooks with Rook after d8 and now Rook 8
to C1 nicely aligning The Rook with the
queen on C7 D captures and C for B
characters and now Bishop to E7 so The
Rook nicely controls the E the D file we
have Queen to E3 moving out of the uh
this Bishop's dag and also now you might
even have some Rook Rook to D1 ID as G4
maybe Knight E5 in the future uh all
depend what La plays really uh Rook 8 to
C8 and now Rook F to E1 and now Bishop
back to G6 the bishop no longer really
useful here the queen is not on this
diagonal The Rook is not on this
diagonal so Bishop to G6 and now Queen
to B3 uh we have Queen to B8 the queen
is still nicely guarding the B7 Pawn but
you free up the C file for The Rook so
now both the the rook and the C end and
the D file are looking very nice and
Here pawn to C5 now this is a very
committal move and while you do give up
the D5 Square for the Black Knight you
also free up the C4 Square for your own
Knight so you can play Knight to C for
the Knight of B6 Knight to D6 Knight to
E5 all of this becomes possible so of
course Knight the D5 lady doesn't wait
uh she just um uh you know puts the
Knight on D5 very beautiful Central
Square where it controls all of these
squares in your opponent's half of the
board uh it doesn't get really any
better than that Knight to C4 and now
Pawn to A4 this is a beautiful Pawn
sacrifice which will give a lot of
activity for the sacrificed Pawn so
Queen captures and now even Pawn to B5
sacrificing another Pawn because now of
course you cannot just move the Queen
the Knight is hanging as well so uh c
cap for some B6 Upper song Knight
captures on B6 and now Knight captures
on B6 we have Queen characters and B6
and now the bishop here is hanging so
Bishop back to A1 with Queen to A5
offering a queen trade uh and uh well
Drew engine except Queen captures Knight
captures and now Rook captures on C8
Rook captures and now okay white is up a
pawn but uh if uh you're not careful
it's not gonna mean all that much so uh
also you have a this D4 Pawn is a
backward spawn you can't really Advance
it uh and uh of course you can't usually
but now you can't and you have to do it
and font and D5 is the absolute best
move here uh the pawn cannot be captured
as the bishop and E7 would hang so here
we have Knight the B3 uh and now just D
captures an E6 Knight the B3 stops The
Rook from capturing an E6 after upon
captures as the bishop on A1 would be
hanging so the characters with f
captures and E6 and now just Bishop to
E5 this gives up the A3 Pawn but the
problem is if you try to defend it yes
you will keep the pawn but then your
position will just be very very passive
the bishop is now under attack and uh
well if Rook captures an E6 trying to
trade Bishops he will just play Bishop
C5 go after the df2 pawn and now white
really can't
um I you know white doesn't really have
anything to show for uh for this extra
Pawn uh so F captures an E6 with Bishop
to E5 and now just the bishop captures
and A3 isolating J eliminates the past a
pawn we have Rook to E3 now attacking
the Knight and Bishop and you have to
defend the bishop to C2 we have Knight
the D4 offering a trainer trade now and
Knight captures on D4 we have Rook
captures on A3 eliminating the bishop
pair and now Knights the C6 attacks the
bishop and here we have Bishop captures
in C6 one would expect to just Bishop
back to beat your Bishop back they want
to keep the bishop pair on the board but
not the Jew engine she decides to pick
up the Knight we have Rook captures and
now Rook the A8 with check why does she
do this uh well uh the bishop pair is
very nice grabbing a pawn is sometimes
nicer so King F7 rooked the A7 with
check and now King the E8 and now Rook
captures on G7 grabbing a pawn and now
she is up a pawn but it's uh you know
okay wrap upon in an end game with the
Bishops of opposite color which still is
not as Droid as there still are Rooks on
the board so you I will be able to also
create threats against your opponent's
king because here the pawns don't really
matter if you can uh if you can start
attacking your opponent's king because
the light Square Bishop uh if the light
Square bishop and The Rook are attacking
the dark Square Bishop can't really
oppose the light Square Bishop so in
opposite color Bishops when you are
attacking it's it's really like your
upper piece this usually goes for uh
when there's a queen on the board still
and maybe a bit uh more pieces but uh
you know positions can be very different
and it can matter in many different
positions so here we have King to f8 and
now Pawn to G4 you have to start
advancing somehow so this is how
juvenile does it Rook to C5 attacks the
bishop and Bishop to F6 with Bishop to
E4 and now King to H2 we have Rook to B5
waiting to see what um uh Juan Jun does
and now Rook to E7 goes after the pawn
if you could put your Bishop on F5 to
control these two pawns that'd be great
but you can't so you have to do it some
other way Rook the B6 and now Pawn to
age for continuing the March forward and
now we have Rook to B3 and what's the
reason behind this Rook the B3 move and
just giving up the sixth Pawn well the
reason is uh you don't really have a
move here if you just try wasting moves
with King to G8 let's see what happens
upon H5 King to a f8 now King to G3 if
you again repeat move spawn to F3 and
once the bush moves doesn't really
matter where Pawn to G5 comes okay
you're gonna start uh we'll continue
wasting moves Pawn to G6 comes and now
this is a problem H captors and H6 and
that's it this will come with check and
the queen comes into the game everything
is defended so you have to play G5 in
order for the bishop to defend this I
mean you uh it's uh it's an attempt but
not really a good one H7 with check
Bishop captures and now of course a rook
to G7 check where you either move the
king away and then you lose the bishop
or you play King dh8 and then Rook
captures and G5 is Checkmate so that
answers the question can we just do
nothing and move working back and forth
and is this a draw just because there
are Bishops of opposite color here no
it's not so okay Rook the B3 l18j forced
to look for Active Solutions and now of
course The Rook captures an E6 grabbing
a pawn bishop to F3 challenges the G4
Pawn G5 and Bishop to G4
uh Rook D7 again going after the H7 pawn
bishop to F5 with King to G2 and now
Bishop to H3 with check King back to G1
and Bishop to F5 we have Pawn to H5 uh
continuing to push forward Rook to H3
now going after the pawn and now Pawn to
H6 so now the question is how do you
break through uh as or everything is in
dark squares and this uh Bishop nicely
controls the H7 pawn and the G6 square
is the is it even possible at uh to win
this well uh yes but black also has to
help a little bit we have rooked the D3
again waiting to see what happens here
how are you how are you to break the
light Square barrier uh King H2 and okay
Rook to H3 with check King G2 we have a
rook back to D3 and now Pawn to F3 uh
Rook back to D7 offering a rook trade
and now Rook the E5 of course you cannot
trade Rooks the opposite color Dash pen
game is a draw so rookie five and now we
have Bishop the C2 uh getting the bishop
out of harms way want the F4 and now
Rook to D5 this is a very nice move and
it was played with some two and a half
minutes on the clock for for late injury
problem is if you capture then Bishop E4
check picks up the rook and then it's of
course a draw uh but uh Joe engine had
some 15 minutes on the clock here she
just moves The Rook Rook D7 and now
Bishop back to F5 we have King to a King
to F2 now comes Rook to D2 with check
King to E3 attacks the rook and now uh
Rook back to D6 here it would be better
to push the white king back with Rook to
D3 check King D2 and you know just keep
the keep the sorry not uh uh yeah uh
Rook to D4 just keep the tension uh
because uh why is this so good well uh
what what do you do here if you play
something like Bishop captures on D4
then King captures on E7 and uh it's a
very strong you're putting pressure on
the F4 Pawn if King's The F3 you can
always just repeat or King to E3 or King
to a three you can always just repeat a
check and the King has to go back but
Rook the D6 was played right away and
now comes Rook the C7 we have rooked the
D3 with check King to E2 and now Rook
back to D5 with Bishop to C3 uh getting
the bishop out and now King the E8 we
have King to F2 uh King to f8 and now
Bishop to B4 with check so switching
this diagonal for this one uh King to E8
and now Rook the E7 with check forcing
the king to come to d8 so King to d8 and
now Rook to F7 uh we have King to E8 and
now Rook the f8 with check King D7 and
now Bishop back to C3 returning the
bishop to this diagonal now with the
King being kicked out of the corner uh
and here the the problem is let's say
you play King to E7 well well possible
it requires quite a lot of calculating
but the point is uh yes you can play it
in Rook captures on F5 is not a
possibility because after Rook captures
in G6 uh you're not winning because Rook
captures an F4 comes with checks we
always have to keep this in mind so
Bishop to G6 was played even though okay
Rook captures on F5 wasn't really a
threat at the moment uh Rook to G8 now
again very very dangerous and now
uh if you go something like Bishop to F5
uh it still doesn't work even though you
don't have Rook captures on G6 you can
play G6 and I have Bishop captures you
will just capture it and the the black
Rook is too far away age captures H7
Rook to H5 you just promote the bishop
of course covers that square Rook
captures Bishop captures and that's it
while of course completely winning here
so instead I have to Rook to G8 Rook the
D6 was played and now Bishop to E5
attacks the rook and here you have to
keep the Rook on this uh sixth rank you
have to prevent Rook captures on G6 you
have to play Rook to C6 or Rook to B6 or
Rook to A6 but a very few seconds on the
clock uh letting J played Rook the D2
check with 20 seconds on the clock but
now it doesn't work but it's not like
you can play anything there's only one
move for white here that wins the game
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this uh well elusive Square
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not playing
something weird like King to G3 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is King to F3 this is the only
move that wins and it wins because it
prevents Bishop to E4 which is uh a key
move for black to defend this position
and uh King to G3 does seem like maybe
uh a move that you you would want to
play but like I said after Bishop D4 it
just doesn't work because after G6 now
okay everything loses if you capture uh
there's a rook to G2 with check that's
the problem and after the king moves you
will just pick up the pawn with the rook
and now it's just a draw however after
King to F3 it's a bit different now it
doesn't work now if you try something
like a bishop T4 is impossible but even
if Bishop to F5 you can still push it to
G6 and after Bishop captures you will
just sacrifice H7 Rook to H2 and it's
the exact same thing h8 Queen Rook
captures Bishop captures and you are
winning this of course very easily so
after King to F3 Rook the D3 check was
played with some 7 seconds on the clock
and now King to G4 we have rooked the D1
uh if if Bishop to E4 again doesn't
really matter just G6 Works in pretty
much every line so Rook to D1 was played
but now of course you all know what uh
dual engine plate she played Rook
captures on G6 and there is no going
back H captors H7 and I believe it was
uh in this position and move 72 that uh
late engine resigned to the game uh as
there is nothing more to be done here so
uh she won game five but now she loses
uh a game eight and juvenile equalizes
the match so we have four more games in
the match with the the match for the
moment uh being a tie uh yeah here you
resigned for the exact same reason Rook
H1 you would just promote broadcast to
be given for the Queen Bishop captures
and of course the position is completely
winning there's there's nothing even to
try here uh so yeah very nicely done uh
by dual engine it was a uh uh you know
uh well played end game at that one
moment she gave up her Bishop pair to
win a pawn which uh not everyone would
do you know people prefer the bishop
pair to being up upon but she went for
it uh she uh said all right uh maybe if
if letting Jay will be able to trade
down Rooks and force and opposite color
bash ban him then it's a draw but if not
uh my chances are good and uh well it
worked out so very nicely done by her
and we'll see what happens in the other
four games uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and that little
bit of info about Chongqing in in the
beginning of the video I would like to
thank David Kimura Rod Hill Phil Malthus
uh Johan Bridger and Richard Phillip
Phillips for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day